a quick nerd alert here
set those intentions now why because as
the song is singing
we are entering the dawn of aquarius and
that's not all tonight the two largest
planets in our solar system
will put on a show that has not been
seen in centuries
you may not get another chance to see it
in your lifetime
mark strassman shows you why you should
go outside
and look at the sky at sunset
astronomer christopher dupree is about
to see something hidden from earth
since galileo first pointed his
telescope at the stars
wow they're both in the finder i've
never seen that before
our solar system's two biggest planets
in one viewfinder
that's jupiter down to the right saturn
up to the left
that's awesome all month just after
sunset
sky watchers have captured the pair of
planets slowly coming together in the
southwest sky
tonight they'll overlap appearing to
merge
into a single source of light an
astronomical
conjunction it's a very slow motion
crash
in metro atlanta debris directs the
bradley observatory at agnes scott
college
whereas in actuality how close are they
oh they're
hundreds of millions of miles apart it's
a bit of a cosmic trick of the eye
yeah exactly just like constellations
are it has to do with orbits
and tilts and cosmic clockwork yeah it's
like a big machine that's just running
forward
and on the 21st is when all those pieces
are aligned just right for these two
planets to get really really close
that big machine is our solar system
constantly in motion
every 20 years jupiter laps saturn
and both planets line up with earth it
is true
that these two planets did come close
actually 20 years ago
but you couldn't see them up in the sky
they were too close to the sun
the big difference here is that you can
actually see him after dark and that's
what's unusual about it
the last visible conjunction this close
was in 1226
nearly 800 years ago tonight's
falls on the winter solstice like a star
of bethlehem
for christmas week 2020. since the whole
solar system is this kind of clockwork
you can wind the clock back for
thousands of years and you can
see where planets would have been at a
time in the past kepler is one of the
astronomers who actually
hypothesized that the star of bethlehem
could have been a planetary conjunction
these two wise men are smart enough to
know
we need clear skies tonight if there are
clouds in the sky
you're stuck with it given how rare
this moment is how maddening is it going
to be
if it's overcast as an astronomer i'm
used to that
you know if you can go out the night
before or the night after it'll still be
an impressive sight
and won't happen again for 60 years
to me some of the most wonderful
experiences that you can do
viewing the night sky are the ones that
require nothing they don't require a
telescope
they don't require binoculars it's just
you looking at the night sky
all you need is your stargazing
curiosity
for cbs this morning mark strassman
decatur georgia